so what aspect
of the brain are useful in this whole
endeavor which by the way i should say
you're you're both the neuroscientists
and
and ai person i guess the dream is to
both understand the brain and to build
agi systems
so you're it's like an engineer's
perspective of trying to understand the
brain so what aspects of the brain
uh functioning speaking like you said
you find interesting
yeah quite a lot of things all right so
one is
um you know if you look at the visual
cortex
um and and you know the visual cortex is
is a large part of the brain uh i forget
this exact fraction but it is
it's a it's a huge part of our brain
area is uh
occupied by just just vision um so
vision
visual cortex is not just a feed-forward
cascade of neurons
um uh there are a lot more feedback
connections in the brain compared to the
feed-forward connections
and and it is surprising
to the level of detail neuroscientists
have actually studied this
if you if you go into neuroscience
literature and you poke around and ask
you know
have they studied what will be the
effect of poking a neuron
in uh level i.t uh
in level v one and uh um have they
studied that uh
and you will say yes they have studied
that so every every possible combination
i mean it's it's a it's not a random
exploration at all it's
very hypothesis driven right like they
are very uh
experimental neuroscientists are very
very systematic in how they probe the
brain uh because
experiments are very costly to conduct
they take a lot of preparation they
they need a lot of control so they they
are very hypothesis driven in how they
probe the brain
and um often what i find is that when we
have a question
in um in ai uh about
have has anybody probably uh probed how
lateral connections in the brain works
and when you go and read the literature
yes people have probed it and people
have probed it very systematically
and and they have hypothesis about how
those lateral connections are supposedly
contributing
to visual processing uh but of course
they haven't built
very very functional detailed models of
it by the way how do
you know studies start to interrupt that
do they do they stimulate like a neuron
in one particular area of the visual
cortex
and then see how the travel of the
signal travels kind of thing
fascinating very very fascinating
experiments right you know so i can i
can give you one example i was impressed
with um this is
uh so before going to that let me let me
give you uh
uh you know uh uh overview of how the
the layers in the cortex are organized
right uh visual cortex is organized into
roughly four hierarchical levels
okay so uh v one v two v four i t
and in we have a v three uh well yeah
there's another pathway
okay okay so there's this this is this
i'm talking about just object
recognition pathway all right
okay and then um in v1
itself um so it's there is a very
detailed micro circuit in v1 itself
there is there is organization within a
level itself
uh the cortical sheet is organized into
uh you know multiple layers and there
are columnar structure
and and this this layer wise and column
structure is repeated and v1 v2 v4
uh uh it all of them right uh and and
the connections between these layers
within a level
with you know in v1 itself there are six
layers roughly
and the connections between them there
is a particular structure to them
uh and um now so one example
of an experiment uh uh people did
is when i when you present a stimulus
uh which is um let's say requires
um separating the foreground from the
background of an object so it is
it's a textured triangle on a textured
background uh
and um you can check
does the surface settle first or does
the contour settle first
cerro settle in the sense that the so
when you find finally form the percept
of the
of the uh triangle you understand where
the contours of the triangle are
and you also know where the inside of
the triangle is right that's when you
form the final percept
uh now you can ask what is the dynamics
of forming that final percept
um do the do the
neurons first find the edges
and converge on where the edges are and
then
they find the inner surfaces or does it
go the other way the other way around
so so what's the answer uh in this case
it it turns out that
it first settles on the edges it
converges on the edge hypothesis first
and then the the surfaces are filled in
from the edges to the inside that's
fascinating uh and
and the detail to which you can study
this it's it's amazing that you can
actually
not only find the temporal dynamics of
when this happens and then you can also
find
which layer in the you know in v1 which
layer is encoding
the edges which layer is encoding the
surfaces
and which layer is encoding the feedback
which there is encoding the feed forward
and what what's the
combination of them that produces the
final person
and these kinds of experiments stand out
when
you try to explain illusions one one
example of a favorite illusion of mine
is the kanetsa triangle i don't know
that you are familiar with this one
so this is um uh this is an example
where
it's a triangle uh but you know the
corners of the only the corners of the
triangle are shown in the stimuli
the stimulus so they look like kind of
pac-man
oh the black pac-man exactly yeah and
then you start to see
your visual system hallucinates the
edges yeah
um and you can you know you when you
look at it you will see a faint edge
right and you can go inside the brain
and look you know do actually neurons
signal the presence of this edge and
and if they signal how do they do it
because they are not
receiving anything from the input in the
the input is black
for those neurons right uh so how do
they signal it
when does the signaling happen you know
does it you know so
so if a real contour is present in the
input then
the signa the neurons immediately signal
okay there is a there is an edge here
when when it is an illusory edge um it
is clearly not in the input
it is coming from the context so those
neurons fire later
and and you can say that okay these are
it's the feedback connections that is
causing them to fire
uh and and they happen later
and you can find the dynamics of them so
so these studies are pretty impressive
and and very detailed
so by the way just uh just take a step
back you said uh
that there may be more feedback
connections and feed forward connections
yeah
first of all this is just for like a
machine learning folks
yeah i mean that for that's crazy that
there's all these
feedback connections i mean we often
think about
i think thanks to deep learning
you start to think about the
human brain as a kind of feed-forward
mechanism right
so what the heck are these feedback
connections
yeah what's their what's the dynamics
well what are we supposed to think about
them yeah so this is this
fits into a very beautiful picture about
how the brain works right
um so the the beautiful picture of how
the brain works is that
our brain is building a model of the
world
uh i know so our visual system is
building a model of how
objects behave in the world and and we
are constantly projecting that model
back onto the world
so what we are seeing is not just a feed
forward
thing that just gets interpreted in a
few more part we are
constantly projecting our expectations
onto the world and
and what the final percept is a
combination of
what we project onto the world uh
combined with what the actual sensory
input is
almost like trying to calculate the
difference and then trying to interpret
the difference
yeah it's it's um i wouldn't put just
calculating the difference it's more
like
what is the best explanation for the the
input stimulus
based on the model of the world i have
got it got it and that's where all the
illusions come in and that's
but that's that's an incredibly
efficient so uh
efficient process so the feedback
mechanism it just helps you
constantly uh yeah so hallucinate how
the world should be based on your world
model and then just
looking at uh if there's
novelty uh like trying to explain it
yeah hence that's why movement we detect
movement really well there's all these
kinds of things
and that this is like at all different
levels of the
cortex you're saying that this happens
at the lowest level or the highest level
yes yeah in fact feedback connections
are more present
in everywhere in the cortex and and um
so one way to think about it and there's
a lot of evidence for this
is inference um so you know so basically
if you have a model of the world and
when when
some evidence comes in what you are
doing is inference
right you are trying to now explain this
evidence using your model of the world
yep and this inference
includes projecting your model onto the
evidence and
taking the evidence uh back into the
model and and
doing an iterative procedure and
this iterative procedure is what happens
using the feed forward feedback
propagation
uh and feedback affects what you see in
the world and you know it also affects
feed forward propagation
and examples are everywhere we we see
these kinds of things everywhere the
idea that
there can be multiple competing
hypotheses
in our model trying to explain the same
evidence
and then you have to kind of make them
compete
and one hypothesis will explain away
the other hypothesis
you